bonjour à tous c'est l'heure de
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire la dernière de la saison
2014 avec un des côtés kate et will der
bonjour rica elle est dans l'actualité
cette semaine un discours très politique
françois hollande a inauguré le musée
national de l'histoire de l'immigration
à paris il a souligné l'apport des
étrangers à la république et dénoncer
les postures politiques de ceux qui
n'aiment pas la france
l'état d'urgence pour les retraites deux
rapports sains de la cour des comptes et
un du conseil d'orientation des
retraites décrivent une situation
alarmante le remède il est bien connu
travailler plus longtemps partir plus
tard à la retraite et puis les hommes
politiques se mettent à la télé réalité
des lives et il se met dans cette ville
aux sept premières émissions sur des 8
la chaîne de la tnt petite audience et
beaucoup de critiques
notre invité cette semaine et roger
karoutchi bonjour sourire ans roger
karoutchi pedersen vice-président de la
commission nationale d'investiture au
côté de christian estrosi dans le nouvel
organigramme de votre parti on va en
parler
nous avons de commenter la semaine
écouter l'avis de quelques uns de vos
collègues sénateurs sur vous oh lord
il est ministre et en particulier
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement ce qui fait qu'en matière de
procédures qu'en matière d'organisation
des votes et d'utilisation du droit
parlementaire il est
et nous apporte son expérience et nous
dit de temps en temps qu'il faut faire
ou ne pas faire comme ci ou comme ça
quand je suis arrivé en 2011
et bien c'est un des sénateurs sur
lequel j'ai pu compter demander des
explications demander de l'aide
et puis avoir un petit peu de soutien
moral voilà quand quand on débute c'est
intéressant d'avoir des collègues qui
vous aide
depuis je le connais depuis 25 ans
d'abord il est historien c'est un grand
historien et donc il ya toujours
beaucoup de subtilité dans ses propos
avec des références que peut on sait ce
qui lui permet d'avoir des arguments qui
sont imparables et le sénateur roger
karoutchi est très chaleureux très
sympathique très cordiale et j'ai de
très bons rapports avec lui même si nous
n'appartenons pas au même groupe
politique les rapports sont bons
j'ai vu qu'il soutenait fermement
monsieur sarkozy
mais c'est presque étrange parce que je
trouve que sa personnalité est assez
différente de celle de monsieur sarkozy
m'enfin c'est une petite remarque ça
vous êtes amstrad et de volontaires sais
pas trop pourquoi
sûr qu'il le dit oh je connais nicolas
sarkozy depuis 40 ans
dire qu'on a le même avis la même
opinion surtout bien sûr que la même
formation j'ai peut-être pas la même
sensibilité sur un certain nombre de
sujets mais quand on choisit de soutenir
quelqu'un est ce qu'on le soutient parce
qu'on se dit on est à 100% d'accord sur
tout ce qu'il dit ou est ce qu'on se dit
c'est celui qui peut faire bouger les
lignes il est chaud sous l oeil puisque
les vidéos je soutiens la capacité à
faire bouger le pays mais non ça ne veut
pas dire que je partage tout les
convictions ou tous les avis non bien
sûr
d'abord je veux revenir un peu sur ce
que disaient les sénatrices qu'on a
entendu au début de l'émission d'un un
peu la pression qui vous considèrent
comme le président du groupe peace
alors il ya eu d'élection et bruno
retailleau a été élu bien élu et je
m'entends maintenant parfaitement avec
lui on travaille c'est que je ressemble
oui oui on n'est pas dedans il n'y avait
pas d' hostilité personnelle c'est ce
truc pareil
autant quand vous avez à l'intérieur du
même parti des relations personnelles
difficiles avec quelqu'un c'est
compliqué après quoi qu'il advienne
autant avec bruno retailleau ou jettent
en bons termes il ya eu une opposition
l'élection a eu lieu on travaille bien
ensemble
j'espère avoir quelque influence sur le
groupe est tant mieux mais ça se fait
mais ça se fait en bonne intelligence
vont venir tourner la page de la semaine
elle a dit françois hollande par
l'émigration
rappelé à la contre offensive politique
de françois hollande le chef de l'état a
profité de l'inauguration du musée
national de l'histoire de l'immigration
à paris pour prononcer son premier
discours depuis son élection sur ce
thème un thème
jugez plutôt sensible écouté décoration
une inauguration en bonne et due forme
pour la cité de l'immigration
l'événement est un symbole pour françois
hollande plus de sept ans après
l'ouverture du musée
c'est ans c'est long pour une
inauguration officielle
il fallait donc qu'elles soient
suffisamment réfléchi pour qu'elle
puisse avoir lieu aujourd'hui
comme si
comme si l'immigration devait toujours
être un sujet difficile dont il vaudrait
mieux ne pas parler ou alors avec
certains mots et dans certaines
circonstances
françois hollande en profite pour tacler
nicolas sarkozy qui a parlé de quitter
l'espace schengen le président annonce
une réforme de la naturalisation
elle deviendra automatique pour les
étrangers qui résident en france depuis
au moins 25 ans et ont eu un enfant
autre sujet très attendu celui du droit
de vote des étrangers
françois hollande l'avait promis en 2012
aujourd'hui il botte en touche
rien ne peut se faire sans une révision
de la constitution ce qui suppose dans
notre droit une majorité des trois
cinquièmes au parlement c'est à dire
l'accord de toutes les forces
républicaines
j'y suis pour ma part favorable à elle
de prendre leurs responsabilités
une loi sur l'immigration est prévue
pour l'an prochain
au programme l'obligation d'apprendre le
français mais aussi la création d'un
visa spécifique pour attirer les
étudiants étrangers
roger karoutchi sur le vote des
étrangers aux élections locales françois
hollande vous tend la main à la base
cette semaine en rien du tout va le nord
où la même histoire
tout le monde sait très bien que la
situation économique politique humaine
identitaire de ce pays ne permet pas
d'avancer là dessus en ce moment donc ça
c'est de la provocation
françois hollande n'a qu'un rêve c'est
avoir un front national extrêmement haut
pour être éventuellement face au front
national au deuxième tour de
présidentielle serait localisation c'est
non seulement de l'instrumentalisation
c'est de la manipulation
et quand je l'entends dire ce qu'il dit
même sur l'immigration
enfin écoutez ça suffit franchement ce
pouvoir incohérent indécent qui n'est
que dans la manipulation dans
l'instrumentalisation ça suffit je suis
de ceux qui à droite ont probablement
sur l'immigration même si je suis
rapporteur sur ce thème à la commission
des finances une position modérée qui
dit
mettons les choses sur la table on est
dans une situation difficile donc on ne
veut pas ouvrir les frontières ça ne
veut pas dire que on oublie ce qui s'est
passé avec l'engagement dans les deux
guerres mondiales des gens qui
participent à ce qu est l empire on fait
aussi la victoire attendra donc la
défense nommé très bien mais franchement
quand je vois qu'il ya soixante dix
mille demandeurs d'asile en france tous
les ans on la corde 4 12 13 milles on
crée volontairement ou pas quarante
mille sans papiers toujours les uns et
on pense plus à l'impression que que
vous n'êtes pas forcément majoritaire
que la politique ce qu'il ya une sorte
de clivage qui se renforce entre la
droite et la gauche sur ce sujet de
l'immigration que là c'est normal que
l'ump proposé des idées est quand même
très bas les idées que bombe aux l'ump
qu'elles sont pas très nouvelle pardon
je le dis vous êtes mode et non mais
quand on lit les quotas on en parle
depuis dix ans de mettre en place des
quotas de grands pays démocratiques je
pense au canada ont mis en place cette
politique des quotas pour entrer dans le
pays
personne n'a dit que c'était devenu des
pays fasciste enfin il faut un peu resté
car si vous êtes d'accord avec cette
fois c'était en octobre dernier prononcé
par nicolas sarkozy à nice l'immigration
menace notre vivre ensemble les j'aurais
aimé qu'ils disent l'immigration
débridée c'est à dire l'immigration non
contrôlée
oui elles menacent sa voiture est
forcément d'accord sur un chiffre pas ce
que c'est ça qui vous le dit c'est pas
l'immigration contrôle et nicolas
sarkozy d'ailleurs pendant la campagne
présidentielle avait parlé d'une
immigration choisie d'une immigration
contrôlée celle là ne pose pas de
problème si on se met autour d'une table
et qu'on fixe les règles mais quand on a
l'impression que plus aucune frontière
n'est maintenue et contrôler que on ne
sait plus intégrées parce qu'elle vrai
sujet c'est pas seulement de dire il
rentre les immigrés ou les demandeurs
d'asile c'est comment on les traite
savez quand j'entends dire
l'apprentissage du français dans le
budget 2015 on a réduit les crédits de
l'office français d'immigration qui
assurent l'éducation aux français qu'on
a réduit considérablement
alors hudson apprend le français parce
qu'on n'a pas les moyens
alors ça suffit de demander dire roger
karoutchi au pinceau mardi on va parler
des compétences pour les futurs
collectivités territoriales il ya eu un
grand débat autour de la carte des
régions maintenant on va parler des
compétences pour ces régions le sénat a
entamé la discussion du projet de loi
sur la nouvelle organisation du
territoire c'est le fameux projet notre
un début de débat car il ne reprendra
qu'en janvier
pauline dames c'est leurs derniers
moments de répit sénateurs et ministres
s'apprêtent à entrer en scène pour six
heures de séance publique
après la définition de la carte des
régions place au qui fait quoi pour les
départements la clause de compétence
générale seraient supprimés ils
garderaient leurs attributions sociales
comme le versement du rsa et la
solidarité territoriale tels que led
milieu rural les régions verraient en
revanche leurs prérogatives renforcées
développement économique emploi
éducation avec la gestion des lycées et
transports notamment la gestion des
routes plus de pouvoirs aux régions et
des intercommunalités élargi leur seuil
pourrait ainsi passer de 5000 à 20000
habitants d'ici fin 2010 est mais déjà
ça coince chacun défendant son pré carré
ainsi gérard collomb à l'origine de la
création des métropoles ne voudrais pas
faire les frais des régions trop
puissante
on donnait des compétences relativement
élargi aux agglomérations aux métropoles
en particulier convient de créer un an
après on supprime ses compétences pour
les transférer aux régions
c'est en tout cas contradictoires pour
quelqu'un qui regarderait d'un oeil un
peu extérieur
le rapporteur de la commission des lois
jean jacques hyest pointe quant à lui le
manque de cohérence générale du
gouvernement
la clarification des compétences
l'intérêt la suppression de la clause de
compétence générale
ça c'est une modernisation nous l'avions
souhaité en 2010 a été supprimée en 2014
est rétablie à la fin de l'année 2014
vous avouerez quand même que la
cohérence n'est pas forcément
première vertu de ce gouvernement un
premier tour de chauffe plus de mille
amendements ont déjà été déposées ils
seront discutés à partir du 13 janvier
prochain des compétences des régions
contre les départs toi ça fait un petit
peu bataille d'égos alors que le froid
on l'a plutôt favorable à cette réforme
je sais pas si il sincèrement beaucoup
de nos concitoyens savent le détail et
parce que en réalité c'est un sujet
extrêmement compliqué de partage des
compétences
moi je suis pour quelque chose de très
clair j'ai un peu basique comme citoyen
finalement par exemple je suis pour la
suppression de la clause de compétence
générale
soyons clair ça veut dire pour que le
département ou la région puisse pas
faire tout et n'importe quoi et
intervenir dans tous les domaines sauf
que là on nous dit suppression de la
clause de compétence pour les
départements et pour les régions et en
même temps on met tellement de
dérogation qu'en réalité et les
départements et les régions pour
continuer d'intervenir dans tous les
domaines du jeu ou pas un seul exemple
la région ile de france
moi j'ai dit en temps présent la
commission des finances cette région que
s'ils ont supprimé la clause de
compétence générale
et si on avait que les compétences
attribuées ces 500 millions d'euros qui
seraient épargnées comme pour les
remettre sur les transports publics sur
l'éducation
mais en réalité les dérogations sont
telles qu'on va continuer de dépenser
500 millions d'euros et qu'on n'ira pas
aux priorités
tout ça est quand même mal fait et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce qui se
passe avec l'alsace est ce que pourront
les parlementaires ump peuvent obtenir
gain de cause et parlementaires les élus
les parlementaires ump de l'est pardon
et scripts à obtenir gain de cause ils
sont vent debout contre construire cette
réforme
écoutez en première lecture le
gouvernement nous avait dit vous jouez
pas le jeu vous ne voulez pas débattre
et tout et on a fait le travail en
deuxième lecture
vraiment on a travaillé sur la carte on
a travaillé sur le nombre d'élus sur les
dates des élections etc
on a beaucoup travaillé et beaucoup
discuté avec le gouvernement
à peine at-on fini et malgré ses
remarques vous ne jouez pas le jeu avec
nous ils evala semblait et il a tout
balayé est-ce qu'elle était folle
donc oui on a fait constitue selon elle
donc on va attendre le retour du conseil
s'il conseille vous
notamment oui bien sûr quand le
gouvernement joue pas le jeu nous ont
pas toutes les armes que la constitution
les sénateurs c'est signé deux ont des
bobos comme cela le recours pour dire la
patrie coupage
il est déposé là ça fait donc le le
découpage ne convient pas les régions ce
qui était une obligation légale n'ont
pas été consultés y a pas eu de vote et
par conséquent il ya un élément décisif
de cette création des cartes qui n'est
pas respectée s'il conseille nous donne
raison et il annulera la délibération
g46 vous savez qu'il ya des élections
départementales dans quelques mois mois
de mars un sondage ou donc ça cette
semaine mais 28% prononce le front
national en tête 25 % pour l'ump suivi
de 17% pour le parti socialiste le fn
est loin devant
oui vous inspire quoi ça m'inspire ce
que je dis depuis des semaines et des
mois y compris à l'intérieur de mon
parti ça va être très difficile et je
dis moi ce sera pire soyons clairs aux
régionales parce que c'est un mode
d'élection qui correspondra plus au fn à
la proportionnelle
cet échec possible échec non parce que
le rejet de la gauche est telle que par
exemple au scrutin départemental le mode
de scrutin va dé favoriser le fn
favoriser la droite classique donc le fn
aura aucune présidences de conseil
général et nous nous allons reprendre
une vingtaine
donc les femmes succès pour la droite
classique par rapport à la gauche qui va
en perdre beaucoup
je suis plus craintifs sur les
régionales ou en décembre
je suis beau sûr que les élections
régionales attire beaucoup plus de 40 %
des lecteurs
et si le front national est toujours sur
sa poussée on aura peut-être un fonds
national aux alentours de 30% ce qui
voudra dire des régions menacées des
présidences de région des groupes
régionaux importants et probablement une
gauche qui va sauver certaines régions à
son profit avec des trilles en connaît
pas la règle ou alors le deuxième tour
avec un fn très fort y aura on va
reprendre un journal accuse on peut pas
mais on va gagner mais peut-être pas
autant que prévu
si nous n'avons pas l'argumentaire la
force de dire un certain nombre de
choses parfois on se reverra d'ici là on
va parler en attendant du temps de
travail
roger karoutchi un autre sujet de la
semaine avec une question les 35 heures
ou tel de l'avenir à l'assemblée une
commission d' enquête sur la réduction
progressive du temps de travail a rendu
son rapport verdict les deux députés qui
ont travaillé sur le sujet ne sont pas
d'accord écoutez moi je pense que c'est
vraiment un outil de la résolution du
chômage et l'expérience qu'on en a assez
que le seul moment où on a vraiment
réduit le chômage c'est à ce moment là
avant il y avait un taux de chômage à
presque 12 % on sort avec aux alentours
de 8 donc scène dans les quarante ans
qu'ils ont passés ça nous est pas arrivé
à cette époque le gouvernement envisage
la création de 700 mille emplois
finalement il en sera créé que 350
milles dans un contexte de croissance
favorables dont les statistiques que ce
soit l'insee ou la dares elle stipule
statistiques du ministère du travail ne
s'est pas nous dire si les 350 mille
emplois c'est ce sont les 35 heures ou
si c'est la croissance
il ya sans doute un peu les deux roger
karoutchi vous revenez au pouvoir demain
avec nicolas sarkozy vous en finissait
avec les 35 heures au moindre coût oui
on a eu tort sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy de ne pas tout faire
mais dieu est grand
le quinquennat françois hollande nommer
tellement à plat est tellement plus bas
que toute façon si on n'agit pas c'est
la catastrophe
donc c'est sur les 35 heures ont coûté
très cher très cher à l'état
très cher aux collectivités très cher
aux hôpitaux ça à déstructurer le
travail dans bien d des entreprises et
des administrations
il faut trouver des solutions il faut
pas que les salariés se disent ah ben
voilà
ils vont nous faire perdre à des rtt on
va où sera pas pme donc il faut trouver
des solutions il faut revenir peut-être
un 38 eur retrouvant des possibilités de
deux gains
mais en même temps on sait bien que
c'est pas possible de rester aux 35
heures c'est pas possible de dire comme
je l'aï entendu encore dire il faudrait
peut-être revenir aux soins à 60 ans
pour la retraite dans la compétition les
prévisions de l'insee 0 27% croissance
pour hollande qui dit bah c'est bien
faire un peu mieux c'est pas mal a
côtoyé ces petits joueurs 07 ça crée pas
d'emplois
le hongrois dont on est content de se
dire vas y aura encore un peu plus de
chômage mais pas autant plus que ce que
j'aurais une bonne nouvelle mais non moi
je
la bonne nouvelle c'est de nous dire 2%
ou là on commence à stabiliser le
chômage mais 0,7 ça veut dire qu'on va
encore créer cent mille à 150 mille
chômeurs de plus pendant l'année 2015
mais franchement je peux me contenter de
ça alors mercredi vers 17 à l'ancien
premier ministre est auditionné à
l'assemblée nationale c'est le gros
toral pour lionel jospin qui a été
auditionné par la commission des lois
avant de prendre la place du fauteuil de
sage au conseil constitutionnel il va
remplacer jacques barrot décédé il ya
une quinzaine de jours nominations
politiques pour votre quartier ou pas
oui enfin je joue pas le sentiment que
ça puisse être autre chose
moi je suis pas choqué je veux dire un
ancien premier ministre au conseil
constitutionnel il a l'expérience
il a géré par un syndicat ou non parce
qu'on en veut
ce mot ça ne paraît pas absurde
peut-être pas aller c'est peut-être pas
le jeune homme de l'année
mais bon après tout c'est le conseil
constitutionnel des gens d'expérience ça
me choque en 2007 le président du snapo
a lui aussi nommé
quelqu'un on murmure un nom en se
rangeant claude bonnart adducteurs que
ce soit le mien quelque 130
personnalités qui aurait sa place au
conseil constitutionnel bon moi je sais
pas je j'avais cru comprendre que jean
claude gaudin souhaitait rester maire de
marseille
même après le texte sur le cumul des
mandats en 2010 7,5 précédemment mais il
en a la capacité et la compétence
mais je sais pas s'il préfère à
marseille pour son attachement réel ou
le conseil autre question compliquée
pour roger karoutchi comment dissuader
les jeunes français de partir faire le
djihad en syrie une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire a été mise en place sur la
surveillance des filières jihadistes
cette commission avait été demandé par
la droite
écouter eric ciotti les travaux de notre
commission diront si ces moyens sont
suffisants ou si comme je le pense
aujourd'hui il faut encore les rend
forcément tout cas je le dis ce qui a
été fait est positif
j'approuve ces dispositifs je soutiens
cette politique parce que face au
terrorisme
nous devons adopter une unité une
posture d'unité nationale et qu'est ce
que vous dites roger karoutchi que peut
faire la france pour dissuader ces
jeunes de partir les déchoir de la
nationalité française
parmi les mesures évoquées y est ça le
premier élément est là je partage l'avis
d'eric ciotti il première éléments je
crois que bernard cazeneuve là tu est
assez déterminés c'est lutter contre les
réseaux sociaux tous les sites qui a
réalité en doctrine pousse un certain
nombre de jeunes à faire le djihad est
vraiment il faut de vraies mesures
maintenant il faut les fermer ces sites
il faut arrêter ceux qui sont
responsables de ces sites il faut les
faire condamner les réserves a donné des
filiales de kerroch rue louis enfin tous
ces sites insupportable qui explique
qu'il faut les tuer les gens ça suffit
ça suffit
d'accord est la deuxième mesure
j'entendais mois quand des gens qui ont
fait le jihad qui sont là bas et qui
disent qu'ils donnent des avocats pour
savoir comment revenir en france sans
risquer de peine avocat ou pas avocat il
faut que les peines soient telles que
les gens se disent
si on part on vient pas voilà qu'elle
est j'y revienne est allé président de
la république elles sont ouvertes à
passer sur un autre sujet on va parler
des autoroutes rien à voir évidemment
mais ce sont aussi des rapports
parlementaires qui sont à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat le bras de fer
autres l'état et les sociétés
d'autoroutes a vraiment commencé le
parlement réclame pour au moins se
prononcer un débat au parlement
regardez ce reportage de marine c'est un
bras de fer qui a démarré depuis
plusieurs semaines entre l'exécutif et
les sociétés d'autoroutes
trois ministres ségolène royal emmanuel
macron et alain vidalis négocié avec les
sociétés concessionnaires
ce travail il est menée dans l'intérêt
général tout en tout est sur la table
tout est sur la table tout est sur la
table car il faut trouver de quoi
financer les infrastructures de
transport alors que l'écotaxe a été
abandonnée et que les finances publiques
sont dans le rouge depuis le mois de
septembre et le rapport de l'autorité de
la concurrence qui dénonce les rentes
exceptionnel l'exécutif s'intéresse de
très près au pactole des sociétés
d'autoroutes pour récupérer une partie
des bénéfices l'état envisage plusieurs
pistes comme le gel des tarifs des
péages ou encore faire financer des
milliards d'investissements sur le
réseau par les sociétés d'autoroutes
ultime possibilité rompre par
anticipation ses contrats de concession
et tout renégocier
mais alors les pas de se décider avant
le 31 décembre soit dans deux semaines
deux rapports émanant l'un des sénateurs
et l'autre des députés ont été rendus
publics aujourd'hui peut-être
éclaireront t-il l'exécutif sur la
stratégie à adopter ou pas ces choses
autoroute fait le symbole de la roque
je sais pas c'est sa valeur de ce que je
sais c'est que si on disait par exemple
avant le 31 décembre
on met un terme aux concessions on remet
ça
sous l'autorité de l'état ça coûte 20
milliards sincèrement vue
le niveau budgétaire de la république de
l'état français d'aujourd'hui où est ce
qu'on trouve un milliard en a plus en
moi j'aime tout le monde
enfin si on trouve un milliard comme me
le disent parce que on sen a fait plein
d'amendements pour l'apprentissage
machin était ça coûtait 10 20 50
millions que vous ayez plus un sou là on
trouve un milliard c'est pas crédible
comme on est alors après est-ce qu'il
faut re négocier à la société
d'autoroute sur villa riffs sur le
niveau d'investissement et sociétés
d'auto 10 nous faisons beaucoup
d'investissements c'est nous qui
construisons les flinois secteur auto
tune et crois moi il faut pas il faut
croire jamais personne qu'il faut tout
vérifier
non mais il faut tout vérifier leur
liste et si on a le sentiment qu'on peut
leur imposer
soit un gel des tarifs est ce soit un
gel des tarifs supplémentaires il faut
le faire quand elle dit proposition de
geler les tarifs soit bien d'accord avec
moi je suis plutôt pour à condition
qu'on démontre que elles constituent des
pactoles qu'elles n'utilisent pas dans
l'investissement
si en revanche tout ce qui est gagné et
réinvestit c'est compliqué alors en
cette fin d'année l'occasion se présente
de faire un petit point sur la côte de
popularité des uns et des autres
notamment au sein de l'exécutif c'est le
zoom de la semaine
jérôme sainte-marie est en piste
bonjourbonjour politologue président de
pôle inbox alors cela fait des mois
qu'elle est en chute libre et là miracle
elle remonte la cote de popularité de
françois hollande est ce que c'est le
deuxième temps quinquennat qui commence
moi j'aimerais le croire c'est toujours
plus intéressant pour un sondeur si vous
voulez de voir des cours qui s'inverse
qui redoute la j'aimerais le croire d'un
point de vue technique on aime autant
vous exprimer c'est quand vous êtes à
12%
c'est mécanique que si les choses ne
vont pas trop mal s'il n'y a pas eu une
catastrophe dans la gestion
gouvernementale une énorme bourde sarr
le bouchon remonte presque naturellement
qui peut croire que la gauche
d'aujourd'hui à 12% simplement dans le
pays ce n'est pas réaliste
donc effectivement on avait atteint de
tels niveaux elle cette rentrée
cataclysmique pour l'exécutif avec
chaque jour ou presque
une nouvelle mauvaise nouvelle une
démission en affaires et c'est
évidemment le bouchon était tenue à
officiellement trop bas si j'ose dire là
c'est la loi de la pesanteur politique
naturelle qui s'exerce encore une fois
vous l'avez dit c'est 18% alors ils dé
mesure où c'est un peu plus haut un
soyons objectifs mais c'est quand même
un niveau extrêmement bas on ne voit pas
exactement pour vous répondre
en quoi il y aurait un second souffle du
quinquennat vous savez les fonctions de
nouvelles stratégies qui serait mis en
place à la rencontre des français
sur le plan international avec des
propositions sur l'immigration un peu de
se différencier non je ne crois pas
simplement vous devez à peu près la même
la machine gouvernementale et la commune
une machine élyséenne qui semble
fonctionner à peu près depuis quelques
semaines si vous voulez les choses qui
sont annoncés soit à peu près tenu les
rendez vous sont les centres sont
respectées enfin bref des choses qu'on
n'avait pas vu avec avec le cataclysme
donc enfin rappelez vous au niveau de la
vie privée du président la république
comme au niveau de son image publique on
avait des choses extraordinaires en ce
début d'année
là vous et les français enfin les
français sondés où les français qui ne
le sont pas ont un jugement sur la
politique qui est assez raisonnable et
sears il devait modifier leur point de
vue ça serait parce que les chiffres du
chômage s'améliorerait ce n'est pas le
cas ou parce que y aurait de nouveau une
un message très à gauche qui sera
envoyée rappeler à gauche qui sera
envoyé plus cohérents avec ce
qu'attendaient les électeurs de françois
hollande en 2012
pour l'instant on ne voit rien venir
roger karoutchi vous froncer les
sourcils le fait qu'il va passer de 10 à
20 c'est plus dur que de 40 à 50 quoi
bon c'est bien que quand on est aussi
bas moi je fasse le plus facile où il
donnera ses revendeurs
oui ce que je veux dire c'est que moi je
ne crois pas que l'électorat de gauche
et disparus et je le dis à l'internement
partie attention il ya une déception qui
conduit à l'abstention ce qui donne le
sentiment mécaniquement que la droite
est en forme etc
pour autant on verra dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent si l'exécutif
ne parvient par un mobiliser son
électorat il perdra toutes les élections
jusqu'en 2017 si il a la capacité de
remobiliser un peu on aura un projet wii
pour illustrer ce qu'il a trop dit je
suis d'accord c'est c'est le fait majeur
pour la gauche en 2007 année en 2014
je vais peut-être vous surprendre c'est
la perte la ville de limoges
l'hymne aux femmes enceintes dans la
gauche depuis 35e libéré parviennent
avant la première galerie et donc vous
avez cette ville qui a même une
sociologie de petits fonctionnaires de
retraités etc
quelques et qui devrait drainer gauche
et qui a été perdue spectaculairement ça
prouve bien que la crise interne
si vous voulez l'affaissement de la
gauche sur elle même en quelque sorte
autre symbole aussi peut-être
autre personnalité de cette année 2014
alors autant nicolas sarkozy
là aussi encore un nouveau sondage - sas
points 67 % d'opinions favorables
c'est vrai que la chute était attendu
une fois qu'il revient dans le bain
politique
enfin c'est quand même brutal 7% où il
présentait pas si attendu que cela je
dis un peu sévère pour l'exécutif je
veux l'être maintenant pour nicolas
sarkozy
chacun passe encore mais dans la mesure
où là effectivement il ya eu une rentrée
qui était devait imposer la candidature
futur de nicolas sarkozy comme une
évidence en tout cas à droite
alors on a toujours le clivage gauche
droite très fort sur l'image de l'ancien
président de la république ça n'a pas
changé
ce ne devait pas changer d'ailleurs par
contre on n'a pas eu de ralliement
massif contre rien pour ne rien dire des
cadres de l'ump
mais même parmi vous l'avez des chiffres
parmi les anciens électeurs nicolas
sarkozy par mes sympathisants de l'ump
il n'y arrive tout cela n'a rien d'une
évidence et le score relativement
partagés finalement pour la présidence
de l'ump à installer l'idée qu'il y
avait une compétition légitime au sein
de la droite
roger karoutchi compétition estimé
n'aurait comme ça en fait je suis pas
tout à fait la fin je suis d'accord avec
l'analyse mais nicolas sarkozy revenait
d'abord devant les adhérents et on sait
que le vote des adhérents est plus à
droite plus clivants que le vote des
électeurs de droite
donc forcément il a pendant deux mois a
pris des positions qui pouvait ne pas
plaire à un électorat centre-droit
jamais plaire à nos adhérents qui nous
ont pas pu nommer sur un point ce sujet
je les dis au début moi je suis
sarkozyste je ne suis pas sarkolâtres
par conséquent je soutiens nicolas parce
que je pense que c'est lui qui peut
faire bouger les lignes
pour autant je suis pas d'accord sur
tout ce qu'il dit heureusement je pars
au beau ni un clown
donc maintenant on est sorti de la phase
élections internes
il ya une phase de reconquête de
l'opinion elle est d'ailleurs au delà de
l'électorat centre droit elle est
surtout les français pour que les
français retrouvent un peu de présidents
la loque obligé de se recentrer
maintenant à moi je pense que dans les
mois qui viennent nicolas sarkozy va
devoir prendre des positions fermes sur
un certain nombre de sujets parce que
les français l'attendent immigration
sécurité et en même temps il va devoir
ouvrir et son coeur et son esprit un
électorat qui n'est pas naturellement
avec nous
jérôme sainte-marie whisky et souligner
une fois de manière c'est que quand même
aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
idéologique le l'ump comme structure
mais surtout comme électorat comme
mouvance dans l'opinion et
idéologiquement c'est très partagés en
réalité vous avez bien parce qu'un autre
phénomène majeur de 7 cette année pour
sortir un peu des sondages c'est le
succès éditorial d'eric zemmour cédé
pour vous c'est l'événement bel
événement majeur à son caisson en
événements pour la droite parce que vous
savez c'est un livre à 22 euros et
quelques enfin bref donc c'est pas
forcément un électorat très populaire
qui l'a achetée et on voit bien que
parme et le corpus classique de la
droite et beaucoup de gens sont
sensibles à ces thèses
alors que d'autres ne le sont pas du
tout donc on voit bien que d'un côté
vous avez dit l'autre côté où le front
national est entre les deux vous avez
son grand parti qu'est l'ump qui avait
vocation à rassembler c'est tout le
monde et qui en fait aujourd'hui al
court le risque je dis pas que c'est
fait mais courent le risque d'être
déchiré en réalité entre ce pôle
centriste est le pôle extrémistes et
celui qui peut faire la synthèse
d'invoquer du nathalie kosciusko morizet
fondateur d'un chalet oui mais bien sûr
c'est compliqué me croyais que le pays
simple en ce moment mais je pense qu'il
peut faire la synthèse
alors il faut qu'il écoute les uns qu'il
écoute les autres et qui tranche mais le
pays est tellement à vau l'eau tellement
prénom votre prochain party pardon
j'avais une proposition je les ai déjà y
est donc moi j'ai dit puisqu'on ne veut
plus des sigles et cetera jeudi que
france rassemblée ça me paraissait très
bien les jeux seront dix ruches f
il a dit que j'avais plein d'idées que
c'était pas forcément sa porte
merci d'enquêter sur notre plate on
passe à jeudi avec un sujet explosif qui
revient dans le débat public l'avenir de
nos retraites
les caisses de retraite complémentaires
sont dans un état alarmant c'est le
constat fait par deux rapports celui du
conseil d'orientation des retraites est
celui de la cour des comptes pour y
remédier les juges de la rue cambon
suggère notamment un nouveau recul de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
elsa monde un gars à une situation
alarmante dans un rapport la cour des
comptes souligne que les caisses de
retraite complémentaires sont au bord de
la faillite
elle pourrait se retrouver en cessation
paiement en 2018 pour l'agirc le régime
des cadres en 2025 pour l'arrco celui
des salariés
depuis 2008 les déficits se creusent en
raison de la crise et de ses
conséquences l'augmentation de la masse
salariale réelle a été quasiment nulle
et cette situation a favorisé la
réapparition des déficits
au delà de la diminution des frais de
gestion et la possible fusion des deux
caisses
la cour des comptes préconise d'agir sur
tous les leviers disponibles baisse des
pensions augmentation des cotisations ou
recul de l'âge légal de départ sans pour
autant privilégier une solution face à
une autre lorsque je lis ou j'entends
que la cour préconise tel report des
bornes d'âge où une telle diminution des
pensions non ça fait partie des pistes
qui sont sur la table
on nous reprocherait bien évidemment de
ne pas les mettre sur la table au niveau
de la réflexion ce qui est notre mission
nous devons bien évidemment mettre sur
la table toutes les hypothèses
et puis après bon en toute connaissance
de cause et en toute responsabilité les
partenaires sociaux prennent leur
responsabilité c'est en effet aux
partenaires sociaux qu'incombe la
gestion des retraites complémentaires
les syndicats de salariés sont hostiles
au recul de l'âge légal de départ
ce que le patronat avec l'âme au
contraire ils se réuniront pour trouver
un nouvel accord au premier semestre
2015 alors que dit-on à l'ump sur sur
les retraites il ya une urgence il faut
une piste
enfin c'est beaucoup sont pour le recul
de l'âge alors il est à 62 je pense que
la proposition d'ailleurs sur les
retraites complémentaires de passer
progressivement à 64 ans c'est la bonne
solution si on supprime les 35 heures
c'est plus d'heures travaillées dans
l'année c'est un peu plus d'années de
travail pourquoi parce que je pense
sincèrement que si on demande aux
français
est ce que vous êtes disposé à ce que la
64 65 64 ans quand vous prenez votre
retraite vous ayez une pension beaucoup
plus basses puisqu'on parle
éventuellement la baisse des pensions
ils diront non et légitimement dire non
parce que quand vous avez travaillé 42
43 ans est pas envie qu'on vous dise au
bout vous aurez une retraite diminuer
considérablement
parce que vous avez le droit de vivre
bien correctement en tout cas donc je
pense qu'il faut se dire avec l'âge qui
avance avec la capacité de vivre plus
longtemps
on peut aller jusqu'à 63 64 ans sauf cas
particulier c'est évident que les
positions très pénible peuvent pas mais
on peut aller jusqu'à 60 80 en ayant la
garantie d'avoir une vraie pensions de
retraite digne pour pouvoir vivre
quelques optimisations s'illusionner si
vous cotisez plus longtemps et si nous
avons ce qui est le cas en france une
natalité démographie suffisante
vous êtes allez vous savez on dit tout
va mal et en même temps on nous dit mais
par exemple le régime général des
retraites
il pourrait être à l'équilibré à partir
de 2020 21 parce que la démographie
permettra de commencer mais c'est tout à
fait normal
donc c'est très bien prévoyons faisons
en sorte que les gens ne subissent pas
de contrecoup à l'âge de la retraite et
et veillons à adapter il faut pas que
cette ce cette politique sur les
retraites soit un problème permanent
il faut s'adapter on passe à 64 ans
parce que pour le moment il n'y a pas et
si dans 20 ans on a beaucoup de
ressources
mais s'ils font venir à 63 ans viendra
pas mais adaptons qu'est ce que vous
pensez qu'il y aura une deuxième loi sur
les retraites
à l'avant la fin du quinquennat françois
hollande je n'y crois pas parce que je
pense qu'ils sont pas très courageux
mais il y en aura une après est-ce que
vous pensez que notre système de
retraite
répartition est menacé par les verts des
retraites privées non gens sur marge
possible
ça fait 20 ans que tout le monde dit
qu'il est menacé mais il n'est pas
menacée si on prend les mesures si on
était un peu pathétique on dire aux gens
vous trouvez que votre toit si vous
arrivez pas mais moi je suis pour qu'on
dise on va sauver vos retraites
simplement où le travail et 62 ans
enfin sur le dos de travail non pas 60
heures jusqu'à 62 ans
est-ce qu'il faut que la loi d'airain de
sophie ou dont on évoluera mais on
évoluera progressivement va pas le dire
la semaine prochaine et on fera en sorte
que dans les 10 15 ans eh bien les temps
durent plus longtemps c'est elle va
faire à ce sujet un petit peu plus léger
les politiques qui se mettent à la télé
réalité au chaud pas si c'est plus léger
c'est une nouvelle émission de la chaîne
des huit que vous pouvez voir sur la tnt
elle déguise des politiques pour leur
faire découvrir la vraie vie est belle
continue de susciter beaucoup de
réactions beaucoup de critiques on va
regarder quelques extraits de cette
première version ec simon barbarie
semble impossible et même elle-même mtv
je passe au pouvoir
et fort la voix et willy mission
impossible de louer un appartement
lorsqu'on est mère célibataire avec un
salaire de 1200 euros par mois et oui
c'est compliqué aussi d'utiliser les
transports en commun à paris lorsqu'on
est handicapé
tous ces petits obstacles quotidiens ça
peut quand on est dans un fauteuil quand
les mobilité réduite se révéler comme
étant un vrai problème
mais qui sont donc ces personnes qui ont
découvert l'eau chaude lundi soir sur
des 8 es bien des politiques mais sous
couverture c'est le concept de
l'émission politique
ander cover de la chaîne du groupe
canal+ pour ce premier épisode 4 élus se
sont prêtés au jeu
la sénatrice socialiste samia ghali le
maire-adjoint du 12e arrondissement de
paris jean luc romero et deux députés
ump bernard accoyer et thierry mariani
déguisé en citoyen lambda
l'idée est de les confronter aux vraies
difficultés des français
plus on est élu depuis longtemps plus on
vit dans la sphère protégée
quelle qu'elle soit et en particulier
dans la seine
la sphère où vivent les parlementaires
que nous sommes plus nous avons besoin
de cette cette immersion si la démarche
des participants d'attirer l'attention
sur un problème social ou sociétal
semble sincère leurs déguisements et
leur surprise face à des problèmes
parfois évident du quotidien atteste
l'idée que les politiques vivent bien
dans un monde à part
alors que les français ont une image de
plus en plus négative de leurs
dirigeants
pas sûr que ce programme les rapprochent
de leurs administrés mais encore
faudrait-il qu'ils puissent juger
l'expérience l'émission n'a pas encore
trouvé son public
seulement six cent mille téléspectateurs
étaient devant des huit lundi soir c'est
pourquoi il ya déjà longtemps j'ai dit
non d'abord parce que je pense que je
suis un français comme les autres je
prends le bûcher des beaucoup de gens
handicapés à monter plus je prends le
métro je n'ai pas besoin de me déguiser
où les gens se précipitent pas sur moi
dans la rue voilà la réponse à des jets
juge pas si certains veulent le faire
qu'ils le fassent
je pose pour votre commentaire moi je le
ferai pas parce que je fais partie de
ceux qui considèrent que c'est déjà très
difficile d'avoir un peu de crédit
politique on n'est pas des verges
la parole poétique je ne sais pas si ça
dessert jean sérien sincèrement mais ce
on a déjà du mal quand on est nous mêmes
à être crédibles existent pour avoir en
plus des caméras
si je veux
voir ce que ça donnerait avec 1200 euros
par mois de louer un logement
je le fais je fais pas une télé avec moi
c'est des spectacles au fond n'a pas la
place un peu quand même du spectacle oui
moi j'ai pas besoin de me déguiser pour
pour me mettre dans des situations où je
me dis c'est difficile cela a été comme
dominique bussereau lui vient d'accepter
par bébé très bien mais si je réserve
mes ceux qui veulent le faire parce
qu'ils le sentent parce que j'en ai
envie c'est leur problème
moi je le sens pas voilà je sentais pas
et bien voilà pas merci on fait des
émules dans le monde le fait très bien
joué mais j'étais sûr saison merci
d'avoir l'invité de parlement hebdo
c'est la dernière de l'année
on se tire une l'an prochain passer de
bonnes fêtes roger karoutchi passer une
bonne fête
chattez spectateurs à bientôt et merci
beaucoup à faire
non